[Music]
right and it is my privilege to welcome
all of you tonight to this second Ford
MIT Nobel laureate lecture the Institute
is tremendously grateful to the Ford
Motor Company for their sponsorship of
this lecture series we started this year
and will continue next year we hope with
three or possibly four such lectures
Ford is represented tonight by dr.
Christopher McGee who's in the second
row here in the center section Chris
Chris is a visiting engineer at MIT he
has served this year as a member of the
organizing committee for this lecture
series and we're pleased to have him
present here tonight with his wife
Joanne our speaker tonight dr. Charles H
Townes received the Nobel Prize in
Physics in 1964 for and I quote
fundamental work in the field of quantum
electronics which has led to the
construction of oscillators and
amplifiers based on the maser laser
principle end quote
dr. Townes holds the original patent for
the maser for those of you who may not
be familiar with the term my memory is
that it stands for molecular
amplification through the stimulation of
emitted radiation and he holds jointly
with his brother-in-law
Arthur shallow the original laser patent
light amplification through the
stimulation of emitted radiation this
work was done largely at Columbia
University I don't have to tell anyone
here about the enormous impact which
coherent light and the laser have had on
the world there is hardly anything one
can touch without coming in contact with
the fruits of those
inventions if you consider the utility
of lasers collimated light coherent
light in instrumentation scientific and
technical instrumentation consider it in
medicine where it is used in all kinds
of diagnostic ways it's used for surgery
in optical communications we will soon
be in an age in which in which all
communications is transmitted on the
earth at least by optical methods rather
than by copper wires and in all manner
of daily conveniences such as the CD
player or the cd-rom player and your
computer all depend on the laser dr.
Townes is no stranger to MIT he served
as Provost of the Institute in the
administration of Julius Adam Stratton
from 1961 to 1965 and that's when I
first met him as an assistant professor
in electrical engineering dr. Townes has
also served on the faculty of the
University of California in the
distinguished position of university
professor and he is now professor in the
Graduate School at the University of
California at Cal Berkeley Charley
explained to me before dinner that Cal
has this enlightened policy in which
emeriti professors if they wish to
continue to do research or to do some
teaching may continue with the title
professor in the graduate school and he
explained that he is one of the pigs
right professor in the graduate school
dr. Townes has frequently served as
advisor to the United States government
and indeed to government's elsewhere as
well he was a member and served as vice
chairman of the president's science
advisory committee in the Johnson
administration he was chairman of the
technical advisory committee for the
Apollo program through the time of the
first lunar landing he's been active in
the work of the National Academies he's
a member of the academies of science and
engineer
and has been active in their work with
the former Soviet Union on arms control
with China and with other nations he
serves has served as a member of the
papal Academy of Sciences and has
provided advice in that manner to the
Pope on arms control and that the search
for peace dr. Townes has an
extraordinary list of honours beyond the
Nobel Prize from academies and
scientific societies across the world
not just in the US but across the world
after his remarks this evening he will
welcome questions from the audience
his addresses as you know is entitled
the black hole at the center of our
galaxy I should say now and will remind
you again at the end that there will be
a reception following this lecture in
Lobby 13 which if you go through any of
these doors and out in that direction in
the northern direction is just down a
set of stairs there'll be a reception to
which you're all invited following the
lecture and the questions please join me
now in welcoming our distinguished
speaker speaker
Charles H Townes
[Applause]
thank you very much for that very
generous introduction I want to say it's
a great pleasure of my wife Frances and
I to be back here at MIT we spent five
fascinating years here back in the 60s
and it's a pleasure to be back and see
some old friends and see all the great
things that are happening at MIT yes I
will talk about the black hole and the
Sun of our galaxy and but in doing that
I must also talk about our galaxy very
generally many aspects of it now the
work I'm going to discuss will be that
of many people and my students have done
some things on the black hole yes but as
in much of science the growth of science
and the new ideas of the contribution
for many people with many different
techniques and you'll see that
illustrated first there let me remind
you what a galaxy is like particularly a
spiral galaxy
sees I have a point of view these are
black-and-white pictures of spiral
galaxies and as one we're seeing face on
you might say this is one that's rather
tilted you see that it's almost like a
pancake shape if we tilt it more it be
still thinner and materials going around
what you're seeing here is largely stars
and these galaxies have a few million
few billion stars in them generally they
vary inside of course the center of the
galaxy would be here now we ourselves on
earth about about a third to half way
out from the center so we're sort of a
long about in here and we try to look
into the center we can't see it with
visual light astronomers couldn't see
into the center of our galaxy a long
time in fact it was only in the early
part of the last century that people
realize we were in a galaxy
there it was all the time the Milky Way
you look at the Milky Way that's we
looking out towards all of these stars
in the Milky Way is the plane of the
galaxy of a flat pancake shaped thing it
was there all the time
but we only realize that hey we are in
the galaxy and there billions of
galaxies out there we're just we're just
one of them now
[Music]
the center of the galaxy was invisible
because not only are there stars in the
galaxy but there are guest clouds and
these gas clouds have dust particles in
them and so on so if we try to look
through the center of the galaxy we only
see the nearest stars and we can't see
very far because of the best in the
clouds and optical astronomers and
visible lights wouldn't get to and
didn't see them for many years the first
discovery of the center of the galaxy
actually was made by an engineer and
this is typical the accidents that occur
in science people who are curious and
they investigate and they're careful
engineer Jansky at Bell Telephone
laboratories discovered microwaves
coming from a particular position in the
sky and with the help of astronomers he
recognized this is where the center of
our galaxy probably is and it was a very
strong microwave source that stayed
there for some years people didn't know
what to make of it I didn't do too much
about it they didn't know what to do and
only later it began to be studied more
and more on radio waves began to be more
and more very important to for astronomy
1968 gents keys worked was in the mid
30s 1968 we had for the first time
discovery of infrared waves coming from
the center of our galaxy and that that
was that was done by Becklund a student
in Naga Bauer Naga Bauer was a professor
very distinguished professor and vented
a lot of infrared astronomy and the
student Beckman said well you know I'm
gonna work and be working by myself at
night I can I look at the center of the
galaxy
and Nike Bao says no don't I don't think
you'll find anything they're gonna
bother but he did anyhow
remember that now don't don't take what
your professors say all the time
question it he looked and he discovered
this bright infrared source wonderful
discovery and of course they went on to
create the science from that was
infrared gets through the dust particles
as well as radio waves well no I want to
show you a picture of our galaxy as we
see it from where we are using a number
of different types of waves because
that's what we use we use all the
possible techniques we can and these are
some of the samples right these are some
of the samples
here's radio and this is the Milky well
first let's look at let's look at the
visible light is the visible light
that's the Milky Way I notice a dark
patches in there that's not because
they're not stars it just means they're
dark clouds shielding all the stars and
we didn't wake up to what was going on
there for a long time
finally you recognize that they're stars
they are the dark clouds and the center
of our galaxy is about in there if we
look at it in radio waves it looks much
brighter as bright all through this
region we'll see a more detailed picture
later infrared see this is a mostly
infrared energy or sort of centered here
that's the center of our galaxy
x-rays are x-rays coming from the Milky
Way
gamma rays look at the gamma rays they
come from special spots in the Milky Way
where something very energetic is
happening so that's a kind of a sample
of some of our ways of looking at it now
let me show you
what can be done with an array of
telescopes in the radio region an array
of telescopes honest an Augustine plane
in New Mexico about 29 telescopes in all
space it's very separation in this
particular one case they all they all
nod together and point the sky it's
almost like they're dancing together the
Rays come down there
the signals are joined from all these
telescopes and that gives very high
angular resolution as well as good
sensitivity as all of the telescopes
working together the spread of a long
distance that gives very high angular
resolution and so radio waves have
obtained angular resolution really
better than optical waves so far even
though they're much longer wavelength
here is a general picture of the Milky
Way
taking taken with radio waves whoops let
me say here it is taken with radio waves
that's the brightest part in the center
the Jansky had found the brightness is
proportional to to the intensity of the
radio waves and this is the kind of a
map made with those antennas bye bye
we'll catch him that at Harvard is one
of the more important people is involved
in this particular map and this is the
bright Center now you'll notice some
stripes here also and people call them
threads and snakes and there's a snake
there they call it there's a mouse and
so on those are just named there
supernovae many supernovae in this area
these are super novae that are blown up
many years ago but the remnants are
still there and they can be seen and
this is a plane of our galaxy of the
plane of the Milky Way now let's look at
still more detail that's a that's a
little bit more detail that in
particular is a cross here's about 1,500
light-years 1,500 light-years now right
here the distance light travels in the
years time and it's a it's about
Oh 600 billion miles of the Lightyear
that's 1,500 of them now let's see
looking a little more detail
still again with those same antennas
so-called VL a very large array this is
the bright spot on the very center and
now we're talking about a few hundred
light years across here instead of a few
thousand look at these stripes yeah look
at those stripes straight lines what's
doing that that tells us is a magnetic
field in this direction and radio waves
emitted by electrons spiraling around
the magnetic fields and they emit
microwaves as they go and so this tells
us something about the direction of the
magnetic field and the strength there
are other places any other striations in
here and other stripes that you saw
that's one of the more prominent ones
there's also a very interesting
collection of stars up in the air the
place called the pistil video somebody
thought it looked like a pistol we we
have to find names for these things now
I want to give you still more detail
again with radio telescopes we're gonna
look at this region about this much this
this this much size magnified still more
and the first slide will show us that I
hope you can have the first slide now
these are pictures of various
intensities first here is that sort of
central brightest place this is the red
represents the brightest part of all the
blue is less bright and you see here is
a kind of an ellipse no almost an
ellipse here there was a stripe across
there and now up here we have a little
less amplification and there's a bright
spot there this is another picture of it
a bright spot but it's elongated along
this direction along this direction but
now if we go very weak look at this very
very bright spot still
and this part is cutting blue we will
call it very dim then this part was a
very bright spot there then that bright
spot was first found by Mulliken Brown
in 1974 University of Washington they
did it with different antennas from what
I showed you these antennas have mapped
it out nicely and that bright spot very
intense in microwave energy and they
couldn't resolve it they knew it was
seemed to be a spark so far as they
could tell and they named it Sagittarius
a star censors a star they didn't know
what it was but that was suggesting
maybe it's a black hole and things are
falling into it and I want to produce a
lot of energy what their various other
possible ways it could have been and
nobody knew how big it was or just just
what it was but there there was a bright
spot and there it is you see as we
resolve it more and more this this is
much radio radiation produced by
electron tiny electrons are going around
doing things here but there's something
very peculiar there that is indeed
bright and small know that spot by now
has been resolved with radio telescopes
and this was this was done by a group of
people backer and Lowe at Berkeley and
some others kind of national cooperative
effort though antennas on the East Coast
antennas on the west coast the two
antennas east and west then the long
distance between him was equivalent to a
telescope that big so far as a
resolution was concerned they did what's
known as interferometry and they found
the size of that they measured it three
millimeters using shot microwaves three
millimeters in the baseline of 2,000
miles separation beam telescopes are
2,000 miles basically a telescope that
big and they found it was one sixth of a
thousandth of an arc second in size one
sixth of a thousands of an arc second in
size now that's equivalent
looking at an atom at this distance if
we could see an atom we would be getting
a kind of resolution that the radio have
gotten and that object but they finally
resolved it and for the first time found
out how big how big it was
that's the highest resolution anyone's
gotten yet although bernie burt was here
has achieved something very close to
that with the radio star neon on some
other objects now in addition to that
peculiar object there are many very odd
and bright stars in this region and now
if we take that off I want to show this
is in that so-called pistol nebula and
there's a bright star that's the
brightest star we've ever found it puts
out light which is 10 million times as
bright as the Sun it's believed to be
about a hundred times heavier than the
Sun and it's out there where those
stripes were near the galactic center
but not at very center the brightest
star we know now you'll see as we go
along the in the galactic center is a
wonderful laboratory the center of our
galaxy produces things that we don't see
you can't see anywhere else
conglomerations of matter and not a
falling together and interviews and
things that are going on that we can't
produce in the laboratory they don't see
in nearby stars anything it's a lab it's
a laboratory out there for us where we
can observe and see what's new and
understand and if we have to we can
study it in more detail and it's the
best galactic center we have simply
because it's the closest the others are
at least a hundred times the Centers of
other galaxies at least a hundred times
further away this Center is only about
25,000 light-years away well that's kind
of far but it's the closest one we have
and and furthermore it's close enough
for us to get the kind of detail that
we're talking about here now and I will
I will talk about some more other things
that were found coming from that region
that excited people
as a gamma rays of half a million
electron volts 0.5 1 1 now those of you
who nuclear physicists will know 0.5 1 1
hey that's the gamma rays that are
created when an electron and the proton
come together and annihilate each other
I mean an electron in the present and a
positron come together and annihilate
each other they produce two photons of
that energy
so there's annihilation going up there
and people thought ah that you know it's
probably the black hole probably a black
hole and a lot of energy around there
things falling in that's probably what
it is later found no it wasn't that it's
something about 1/2 1/2 a degree away
from the center when they located where
it was really coming from it's not in
the center what half a degree close by
about half a degree away look it's just
it's recombining positrons and electrons
about 10 to the 12th tons per second
matter being destroyed and it's now
called the great Annihilator the
greatest Annihilator we know when you
know we also have 1.8 million volt gamma
rays coming from this region
I've been discovered 1.8 million
electron volt gamma rays coming in this
region what's that characteristic curve
well nuclear physicists know what is
characteristic of aluminum-26 which
decays and as it decays this is another
atom in that case in produces gamma ray
it has a lifetime of about a million
years and so something big explosive is
happening there within the last million
years or so
supernovae can do that but this would
have to correspond to a lot of
supernovae the intention is so great and
it's spread around the center but around
the center it's in that kind of a volume
area so there's a lot happens happen
there within the last million years some
very explosive things if supernovae then
there were lots of them and more than we
can get an account or expect at the
moment well no let me
let me try to give you an overall
picture here what we see
they're to quickly get an overall
picture here is a milky way which is
what we see accepting with a telescope
you see vastly more stars as I mentioned
galaxies are galaxies actually has about
10 billion stars and so if we look up
there with a telescope we see all of
these little bikes Pakistan are weak
this is the center you see well we might
guess that's a concentrated region might
be the center but what is it we're not
really seeing with into the center we're
seeing just some of the nearer parts of
narrow parts of our galaxy here if you
look into the center with radio waves
you get this first place
you see microwaves coming from this
region which is outlined with lines as a
sort of a area here here is this oval
which I showed you earlier an oval there
and a stripe going across it but in
addition to that there is molecular gas
and this colored matter the molecular
gas we know that again from radio waves
microwaves which detect the radiation
from HCN the rotation of a molecule HCN
so this is a neutral cloud on an ionized
cloud of molecules here we can tell the
temperature the temperature is the order
of anywhere from a hundred degrees down
to about 20 degrees it cools off we get
out here as it cools off it's so cold
that HCN won't even rotate and we don't
see the HCN anymore it's probably still
out here but it's not radiating here it
radiates and then as we go in still
closer we get ionized material which is
what you see here in the original radio
picture that's ionized material this is
done with radio spectroscopy microwave
spectroscopy and there's a cloud of
molecules so we go in from very cold
material it gets warmer there's
molecular material and gets ionized and
then in in here there's practically
nothing in some places and there's
secretaries a star that point right
there said Thursday star okay now we
take a very very magnified picture just
in this region of Sagittarius a star
it's right there but we don't see
anything much there this is in this is
with infrared with a big telescope and
this is 2/10 of a parsec now one parsec
is about three light-years so this is
really about one light year across this
is one you know one light year across is
about eight light years across here this
circle here is a about eight years and I
ate like years and down are we talking
about one light year roughly here and
there's a Sagittarius a star these are
stars at various intensities we don't
see much infrared coming from the region
and yet there's very intense radio waves
let me just show you another picture
with the Keck telescopes this is taken
by UCLA scientist University of
California Los Angeles the Keck
telescopes and again this Sagittarius a
star and these are stars this is very
much very much enlarged to say five
light days is what we're seeing here
very much enlarged and those just seems
to be nothing there now that's
surprising in that black hole what is a
black hole a black hole represents a
concentration of mass which is so
concentrated the gravitational field is
very very large and it's so large that
nothing can get away not even might
shine a flashlight from a black hole a
light goes out a little ways and falls
back in again nothing can get away from
a black hole so such a concentrated mass
now it may be may not be very heavy
could be just have a very small radius
and they have a very strong
gravitational field but typically what
we know of black holes what we think we
know there are bigger objects like at
least as heavy as a star and we'll see
that this one is much heavier and still
a small enough
radius that the gravitational fields are
normally large do you fall in you're
gone you never get out and you're more
that's indescribable from then on it's
just old all matter is all the same and
though that's a black hole and now we
have to expect there should be some
black hole somewhere if our theoretical
ideas are right if things can become so
condensed I've to expect yes so recent
black holes the way we'd expect to find
them well center of our galaxy is a
natural place everything is attract
things are being attracted to the center
of our galaxy we're spinning around them
slowly if we slow down we'll start
falling in a difficult force will
decrease will fall in and so things fall
in things should accumulate there that's
where matter should accumulate and we
should have a very high mass and then
maybe a black hole will develop here is
a still more detailed picture of that
central region we showed and you just
see it again as Sagittarius a star the
so-called western arc which is part of
this ellipse I'll call you will see more
about the ellipse here and this thing is
sort of at the center of this ellipse
and then there's this give this
molecular gas around it which then gets
cold as it goes on out there and then
there's a northern arm pushing material
that seems to be just coming in coming
in towards the center right here the
northern arm and then the are the
ellipse it goes around like this okay no
let me show you another tool which is
used our next slide will show another
important tool in the study of the
galactic center which is an airplane
this is an airplane that flies above
most of the atmosphere tries around
around 40,000 feet why is that
that's because far infrared radiation
doesn't get through our atmosphere with
very very well particularly water vapor
but other parts of the
feel so you want to get above the
atmosphere as much as possible and this
is so-called Cripe observatory built by
NASA you get up about 40,000 feet and
then you open up this thing here we are
back in the middle of the plane closed
off because if pressure is too low here
for us to be in that section that
separated off here and the telescope is
out there telescope can be operated look
out and study waves it can't get through
to the ground now I want to show next
something a result obtained in that
airplane by Gordon Stacy who worked with
us at Berkeley for a while but he did
this particular thing with students at
Cornell he took a he took me mapped out
the fara mid and mid afar with far
infrared generally we would call it in
this region and this is what he found
this is the ellipse that you've been
seeing but you can see it also seems to
go all the way around almost an ellipse
around there secretaries a stars right
in here this is a 30 this is a 32
microns wavelength 32 microns is is what
well 1 micron is 10 to minus 4
centimeters or one thousandth of a
millimeter so this is about a thirtieth
of millimeter wavelength far infrared
this is 38 microns and you see they're a
little different they depend a little
different under 10 different different
neon temperature but you can see it's
pretty clearly elliptical thing here and
something bright coming down there and
across here and then the other warm
things around and this is a this is a
heat radiation from something as warm
but it doesn't is not very warm in order
to put out these longer wavelengths
that's about three times the peak
wavelength put out by the earth at this
temperature
all right no we Berkeley started
studying the galactic center fairly
early not so long after it had been
detected in the infrared at Caltech and
the next slide will shows a couple of
students and I down in Chile Chile is
the best part best place we know on
earth to observe in telescopes because
of the atmosphere is so calm and and and
non turbulent and there is a Tom jabal
and myself and John Lacey Tom is now at
the autumn Hawaii
University of Hawaii and Lacey the
University of Texas and we went down to
Chile partly because of the good
atmosphere but partly because the
galactic center goes right over here
deal for us here we have to look fairly
far south to see the galactic center
like that goes right over here and there
was a nice telescope there and so we
went down there to examine it and we we
decided to examine the gas because we
didn't know anything much about the
center much of what I showed you hadn't
yet been measured and we felt if we
measured the gas the type of gas and
it's velocity maybe we could see whether
whether there's a black hole there
whether things are going around a black
hole
now what gases would we measure well the
radio people seeing waves knew that the
gas was ionized in the central region
and so we would look for ions we could
look for ions of argon or neon or sulfur
and the spectral lines but and work in
the infrared which would get through the
dust
we worked at content microns 10 microns
and mid-infrared it through the dust
look into there and see and by picking
those ions we could tell what's the
energy of excitation because each one
had a different energy of excitation
what's the average end of the excitation
and we found neon was very plentiful our
gun was not so plentiful sofa wasn't
there at all that meant
that the stars producing ultraviolet
there had temperatures up to about
thirty or thirty-five thousand degrees
our Sun is around five thousand degrees
you may know these stars are bright and
hot compared to the Sun but they're not
the hottest type so we get fairly hot
stars but not very hot stars in the
galactic center also this allowed one to
tell the density of the gas identity gas
around ten to the fourth and ten to the
fifth particles per cubic centimeter now
this air we're breathing is about ten to
the nineteenth particles per cubic
centimeter so that's very rarefied about
the best I can we can get on earth but
nevertheless but for interstellar space
that's a fairly high density then the
fourth ten v materials ionized we you
can see what it was what it was also we
could measure the velocity using the
Doppler shift using the Doppler effect
we can measure of life that we found off
some pretty high velocities and for the
study of that showed a good ile about
what might be there and this was
followed up by my students as they moved
on to other places I was pleased about
the opinion and John John Lacey and Jean
Sarah been John Lacey was in Caltech and
in Texas and Sarah Byrne was down
Caltech and here is the ellipse and
these are the points that they measured
they measured the velocity of the gas at
all of these points and along these
points which we call the northern arm
this is the ellipse this is a northern
arm those are points that they measured
and now what do they find
let's look along the ellipse first and
this is what they found
they go from the bottom to the top the
velocity varied bottom ellipse minus a
hundred kilometers per second to plus
100 kilometers thick and now minus
hundred kilometers per second Sean was
used - to say it's coming toward you
five hundred kilometers means it's
coming toward you at a hundred
kilometers per second plus a hundred
means going away from you
well that's just what you'd expect of
something going around in a circular
fashion and you look at it edge on you
can work out the arithmetic is what's
the velocity towards or away from you it
goes exactly linearly with distance up
the ellipse goes exactly linear that's
that's just what almost what it was
doing these variations however are real
those variations from linearity are real
so it's almost a steadily rotating
circle of material but not quite steady
now that says that you notice around
Sagittarius a star there was some gas
yes but there was evacuated material and
then it was gas a little further out
it's the ellipse that says something big
happened sometime in the past this
material was blown out how far in the
past well with these differences in
velocities one could say that this ring
of material different parts would bump
into each other in about 50 thousand
years and they would even out their
velocity I'll go around same velocity
weren't going quite same velocity so
something big has happened within the
last 50 thousand years there in addition
but the velocity one could say well how
much mass is inside of there this is
like the earth circling around the Sun
we know how fast it moves around the Sun
how far away it is we can say well
what's the mass of the Sun because of
gravity is attracting it in significant
force has to equal that attraction so
the mass in there was about 4 million
times the mass of the Sun now this is
only that ellipse has a radius of about
4 light years and about 4 light years is
a distance to the nearest star to us we
have mass of 4 million stars within that
distance within that ellipse were
circulating material Serban interpreted
the so-called northern arm and he found
that was equivalent to another a very
not a circle but an elliptical thing and
that's the position of Ace of
Sagittarius a star there's those points
and they fit very nicely in velocity in
position with an ellipse and the
velocity could say well that yes it
looks like it has about 303 and a
a million times the mass of the Sun and
he comes in fairly fairly close in this
case several times closer than the than
the ellipse laws so that should be in
fairly close within that close that
distances are still about four million
times the mass of the of the Sun all
right now I want to show another kind of
overall picture a diagram to remind you
of some of the things that we're seeing
seeing aside where Sagittarius a star is
is the ellipse this is the western arc
of the ellipse this is the just outside
of that is a molecular material and the
northern arm coming down there we find
has a batch of atomic material again
seen from its spectra and Reinhard
genzel who was Berkeley now now largely
in Munich did much of that work and
there are other things that various
people found radioastron was especially
found that the star here with material
kind of straining out behind it as if
wind or something is blowing that
material furthermore there's a kind of a
cavity here as if something has cleared
that out I thought is well maybe that
was over close to the Sagittarius a star
inside there's a star and a big wind and
blew that out and maybe it's blowing
this out it's exactly in the direction
going from Sagittarius a star this star
where these tails are blown out there
now if we go a little further make a
make a map of a bigger area here is the
striations are spying the magnetic
fields the little striations in here
there's a great annihilator downhill
annihilating positrons and electrons at
a great rate so those are some of the
many things that a wide number of people
discovered and I'll give you a general a
general overall picture no we were
thought we could argue fairly strongly
it had to be a black hole layer because
the very high velocities of gas because
the patterns of motion of the gas but
not everybody wanted to believe that why
because of black hole attracts material
material will fall in it we know there's
a lot of gas here we could measure the
gas a lot of gas there a lot of stars
putting off gas we could measure the gas
we know there must be material falling
in if you calculate what that material
falling in would do would fall in
towards the black hole it would circle
around it get ionized and that circle
around it didn't it a lot of radiation
it emit too much radiation and people
calculated MIT about a thousand times
more than what was seen so it couldn't
be a black hole couldn't be a black hole
of that much mass on you that was the
current theory of the day of the day but
it just can't be that kind of mass or
something something wrong there because
material falling in has got to get
accelerated and ionize and radiate and
it'll radiate far too much now that
argument went on for some time
we felt the evidence was pretty good but
people said well maybe the gas is being
blown by a wind not that's what gives it
a high velocity some kind of a wind or
maybe this magnetic field is
accelerating the gas after all we know
the magnetic fields there well we can
measure the magnetic fields however from
Zeeman effects in the fine structure of
atoms magnetic fields are not very big
the winds we knew something about those
those weren't very big nevertheless
everybody was looking hard for some
other explanation and now this is a not
an uncommon phenomenon sometimes you're
right sometimes you're wrong which you
find some evidence and yes it might be
this might be that and you think the
evidence is pretty strong but it doesn't
agree with somebody else and so you've
got to start all over it and this debate
among scientists
important part of the process and it was
debated for some time now I think it's
been more or less settled and what
really convinced the remaining
astronomers was a measurement of stellar
motion because they felt well the gas
somehow that can be blown around and we
can't rely on gas velocities too much
stars on the other hand are kind of hard
firm objects and there you can't do too
much fancy with them
and here are some stars measured by
gates and very colleagues down at UCLA
using a Keck telescope
here's 1995 a group of stars very close
to Sagittarius a star look at them three
years later you see the difference in
position look this angle the angle
between these two has changed the
distance between these two in position
has changed and so on even one star
which was there has disappeared
changed intensity so the stars
definitely have moved now we know
roughly how far that is we know the
angular moves so we can tell their
velocity yes the velocities are very
much like what was being found with the
gas velocities and that was watched over
several years the first person to see
that motion actually was jinsol and
Eckhart in Munich but gates and others
at UCLA have done a lot of the
measurements too and they agree now
here's some here's Eckert and ensel's
work they plotted the position of stars
as a function of year from 92 we seat
about 2,000 you can see these are the
positions and clearly they have moved an
angle and so from that you can determine
the velocities and you get the
velocities of stars here is a picture
of the various stars and their relative
motions well this is this this is the
scale of velocity that's 500 kilometers
per second another thing that using the
Stars allowed was to get very close into
the center the centers about in here and
some of these stars are very close so
they were getting 500 kilometers a
second the gas that we saw was up to
about 250 or 300 kilometers per second
this is still faster and some of them
faster than that even and here is a
picture very close in with the various
directions and magnitudes of velocities
as I found recently the UCLA group
thinks they have even seen some
curvature in the motion saying now
they've see them circling around and
this is a plot as Sagittarius a star
this is the plot of the positions now
there's some curvature there you might
doubt how certain that is that curvature
but they say well you can plot it in
various ways as very sorts of ellipses
that this might be forming but here's
the best one they think it's going
around the lips like this give them
another 5 or 10 years and they'll be
around here and sure enough they'll
really exactly the orbits and now
furthermore some of these are very close
this one's very close in see that seems
to have some curvature and so we can
plot these ellipses they given or they
give another decade we'll have a very
detailed information about these orbits
exactly what masses they are what the
distances are and we'll we'll know much
more but already we know enough to be
pretty convincing now let's look at the
backs of stars interacting with each
other and how should they behave well
they're very much like molecules they
bump into each other bump into each
other and share energy they should all
have the same energy just like molecules
bumping in each other have the same
temperature they have the same kinetic
energy so when stars are just mashed
together in a in a in a galaxy nothing
else they are they bumping at each other
and sharing energy
all have the same velocity if on the
other hand you have a heavy mass in the
center of the galaxy then the star not
only bump into each other they go around
it and as they go around the velocity
should increase like one over the square
root of the distance does it get closer
and closer to get faster and faster
it's like mercury is closer to the Sun
than we are it goes faster some of your
students might work these things out see
just exactly how they behave it gets
faster and faster as you get closer and
sure enough the velocities got faster
and faster the gas velocity and the
seller velocities got faster and faster
and so you could what then the mass
inside of a given radius as a function
of radius and this is there one of the
one of the latest plots you know using
all the data the gas information gave us
points up to about in here but the
stellar information gives us points
really right on much much closer how
close well up to about 0.02 parsecs now
one parsecs is free like here so that's
that's a 0.06 light-years getting
awfully close and inside of that there
has to be a mass still of about 3 times
3 million solar masses inside of one
sick one 1/16 of a Lightyear even has to
be a mass and you see the mass is pretty
constant this plots the mass as a
function of mass inside of a circle as a
function of the radius of the circle and
it's pretty constant so clearly there's
a central mass inside of inside of a
16th of a Lightyear and that's pretty
concentrated for for 3 million stars and
people say well yeah it has to be a
black hole it has to be a black hole a
black hole about 3 million solar masses
now that that was satisfying in a way to
to come out with an answer everybody's
pretty much agreement now yes however
what about the problem ready
it radiates radio waye it's a good
pretty intense radio waves very very
little infrared it's doubtful whether
we've really seen any infrared radiation
we won't see visible radiation anyhow
because it won't get out through the
dust clouds but we should see end of
infrared radiation how much should we
see we know how much material is falling
in calculations si si would say we
should see at least a thousand times
more than the seen so theorists have
been struggling with well how can we
explain this how can we explain this how
can we get away from it now as a matter
of fact by the time this came out by the
time all this got settled over measuring
period of about 25 or 30 years more and
more data kept coming in but also other
galaxies were being examined and
velocities of materials around the other
galaxies and people were finding heavy
black holes they felt in other galaxies
some of them as large as a billion solar
masses things were going around very
fast now some of those were radiating
very intensely just what was expected
they were radiating tangibly but about
40% of them were not on the case with
distant galaxies you can you can catch
that aside said well we don't know how
much material is very close in we can't
see it may not be much material close in
maybe nothing is falling in right now
okay so those distant galaxies even
though a lot of them are not radiating
the way you'd think maybe there's
nothing falling in what about our galaxy
now when we can calculate how much gas
is falling in we also know that's a star
or to fall in every once in a while when
a star gets as close as the earth is to
the Sun it'll be sort of torn apart torn
apart and made in gas and it will rotate
and fall on in so a lot of stars would
fall in every few thousand years there
ought to be a noose another star falling
and that ought to make a big burst of
energy enormous but we know there's gas
falling in all the time and why not
getting some energy now the Russians
have used the granite spacecraft which
measured x-rays Russians have looked at
the galactic center and near it and all
around the galaxy to see if they could
could they find any x-rays due to this
very energetic source or what supposed
to be agenda a very energetic source
well you find some x-rays coming from
the galactic center not a large amount
but again roughly a thousand times too
small now as they moved out in the
galaxy
said well if we find x-rays out here
those might have come from the galaxy
the center galaxy having a big explosion
x-rays go out and they hit some gas out
here and get scattered towards us so if
you go a hundred light-years away from
the center and see is anything being
scattered towards us you can say what's
did something happen the hundred years
ago and the galactic center
what a wonderful timing device you can
go five hundred years out from the
center and say well did anything happen
five hundred years ago and so on and
they had enough sensitivity they felt to
go out about a thousand years nothing
happened
nothing happened that was big in the
last thousand years there well again
that all this gets pretty serious of
difficulty and let me summarize now by
saying what what we found and what we
understand what we don't understand what
are the see we understand a lot of
things here it's a wonderful laboratory
on you Rosings happening we find a black
hole it's well 2.9 million solar masses
is sort of the best not me but that's
plus or minus 10 percent but about three
million solar masses as a black hole I
think almost everybody is pretty
convinced we also find it peculiar a
collection of stars there a large number
of stars a ruler somewhat like
wolf-rayet stars we call them the stars
in mitting hydrogen and helium and so on
they're hot stars are rather unusual
types out of those stars a lot of new
star
not very many red giants now red giants
is a bright reddish star like Betelgeuse
in Orion a big red star in Orion red
giants very very few of those they're
lots of new stars but our star is only
up to a certain temperature now one
might so there's an unusual formation of
star in that region one might say well
no wonder after all this is a large
gravitational force there and unusual
things clouds being pulled together and
that'll form those stars and of course
it won't be like the stars we see in
other parts of the galaxy however we
don't know just how that what is forming
furthermore if we go about 100 light
years away from the center here's one
another big batch of new stars somewhat
like the ones very close and they're not
all that close to the galactic center
that's this pistol nebula where this
biggest star of all is so there's
something something peculiar in the star
formation that we haven't worked out yet
so don't understand very well why the
star is this particular type a lot of
new stars essentially no all stars
remaining there but most of the new
stars are let's say not very very high
temperature now the lack of luminosity
from Sagittarius a star itself is the
most serious discrepancy and the way the
most exciting of course part of the fun
of discovery is to learn something new
if you've gotten a new tool you can
measure something more precisely measure
something new you find something
unexpected well that's great because
that leads us on the further thoughts
and better understanding and so this is
just great that it we know it's a black
hole
we know the material there must be
falling in but it isn't radiating the
way we thought how to explain that well
the best explanation we have at present
is a following that there's a star
material Falls towards it and then
circles around it and ionized and Falls
and graduate radiating all the time ah
well suppose it just Falls straight in
doesn't circular circulate around
there's no anger
momentum it falls right straight in well
they're going very quickly then and
won't do very much that helps some
however we know where the gas is we know
what the velocity of the gas is we know
it's not all falling straight in but
maybe right now for most of its falling
straight in that's still not enough but
it still radiates too much well maybe as
the fall gas falls in the gas collides
with itself and sort of squirts out in
this direction it comes together like
this and squirts out and that gets rid
of the energy okay well if you if you do
that you make a sort of pull pull the
type a mission like that and say most of
its falling straight in use both of
those you can just about make it and say
well okay that's just about explains
things it's not a very satisfactory
explanation obviously because we've got
to strain ourselves and do some rather
peculiar things and and there we are now
where do we go from here in the first
place clearly we're going to have more
and more orbits and more complete orbits
we'll get very detailed very precise
information about the distribution of
mass secondly maybe there'll be an
outburst there maybe there'll be a star
falling in and they'll suddenly suddenly
be an outburst of radiation there ought
to be an outburst of radiation in fact
these models which attempt to explain
very well they ought to be a very big
variation about every 10 years or so in
the material falling and we ought to see
some fluctuations so we keep watching it
now is not only a question of making
more details or to tell more precise
measurements looking at everything
closer and closer but also simply time
will tell us a lot as we watch it and
see what happens someday a star will
fall in maybe there were stars falling
in the past letting out a big burst
people on earth wouldn't have seen it
because the dust but now that I
instruments it'll be obvious enormous
burst of energy coming out in the radio
and infrared and sowing of a star falls
in that'll be real fun so those are some
of the things that we
forward - thank you
[Applause]
questions comments yes sir and I was
wondering what what would happen you
said there was some intense radiation in
spectrum
see any way of using that to show you
what's happened in the past yeah yeah
well yes that certainly gives us some
hints that there was a very and a very
very energetic explosion of sometimes
some kind within the last million years
or so and there's near the center of the
galaxy but it doesn't pinpoint things
terribly well so within a few million
years it was in a within an area
somewhat bigger than the ellipse around
it and so maybe there were a lot of
supernovae we but on the other hand it
might have been some stars falling into
the galactic center to possible we'd
like to see another event like that but
that's now gone far enough and it's
broad enough we we we don't get a very
precise interpretation affects the
center of universe and expanding
universe like there is a theory that
universe is expanding and the radar
screen sorry would you say that again
speak about more slowly like you people
say that universe is expanding at the
speed of light like if you go towards
the edge of the universe they you dust
the cosmic dust is expanding at the
speed of light so how does the dot
function expanding universe relates to
black holes universe the hole maybe a
black hole - is that what you mean yes
but it's not the kind of black hole we
see here where everything is very very
compact this film could be could be
enough mass and nothing and get away you
might say but it's not like these black
holes that are very very compact and you
can get up closer to them thank you yes
in this laboratory that is this black
hole can be seen we artifact in term of
I don't know conservation of energy and
matter will be able that we don't see in
everyday physics
so can be observed in the black hole
some I don't know unexpected phenomenon
in term of conservation of energy and
matter that we don't observe in I don't
know every day searching in the black
holes
unfortunately we we can't very well get
inside of a black hole we can get inside
of one if we found one nearby but
wouldn't you wouldn't get out again
wouldn't be able to tell anybody what we
saw in fact it's interesting that
they're even troubles we don't
understand black holes very well well
troubles is that if something falls in
it it loses all its history so far as we
know now physics and science generally
says no an object from looking at the
object now in principle you can tell
it's past history they didn't tell where
it came from and what happened and what
develop did you see fall in the black
hole all that passion summation is gone
and unfortunately if we get in the black
hole while we're gone and now how to
experiment with one however if we had a
few small black holes around it would be
fun long who didn't long as it didn't
come to close to us
I think however for the moment we're
stuck with the experimentation being
observing these things and watching
what's happened a little different from
a laboratory where you can tweak things
and play with them in this case you
observe and that's true of most of us
strongly you observe you can't tweak
tweak the device you have to look at it
and watch it and then interpret it and
we can do a lot of that and I and
there's going to be increasing
information about black holes just from
observations but I'm afraid that's the
only way I can foresee finding out more
about them wish I had had one on the lab
myself
please question cosmological conjecture
number one how many of the existing
galaxies do you suppose have black holes
at their centre and number two or anyone
suppose that the black hole may have
existed what's its history did it not
originally exist does anyone have any
ideas about this
yes well from the very beginning and
ideas about black holes I think people
felt that well the center of a galaxy
would be a natural a natural place for a
black hole and then they began to be
discovered we don't see large black
holes in all galaxies however I don't
remember what percent but maybe thirty
percent of them don't have any detected
black hole probably well that thirty
percent of them have a cases where we
think we should detect something and we
don't now that doesn't mean they don't
have some small black hole but they
don't have these enormous big ones but a
good many galaxies do it's a very
natural place for black holes to form as
they as I mentioned so it's not
surprising they range in size also from
the order of a million to an order of
the order of a billion and
and the size of my coals and surely it
depends on the history of the galaxy how
many galaxies have bumped into each
other and maybe combined over there
closely there are concentrated mass that
sort of thing the black hole emits
Hawking radiation
it could be served to any source of
information about what kind of material
is going inside of which amount of
material is going inside if I understand
your question you say well in black Oh
tell us what kind of material is going
inside no after it's gone inside it
doesn't tell us anything while it's
falling in yes while it's falling in we
may be able to say something about
what's there because the electrons and
protons and heavier elements will behave
a little differently as they fall in and
if we can do good enough work and
radiation measurement spectroscopy and
so on we can tell something about what
matter is falling in but once it's
inside of the black hole boundary that
is where nothing can get out well then
we have no hole
what's the closest you can get to a
black hole without being pulled in well
that's a good question how close can you
get to a black hole it depends on the
size of course depends on the size but a
black hole of this size you can't get
any as close to it as we are to the Sun
now you know we're long distance from
the Sun very long distance from the Sun
but we can't even get that close to
black hole of this size now if the black
hole is very very small then we would
get a lot closer because the black hole
will pull things into it but you have to
get pretty close before you'd be
snatched and can't get away so it
depends on the size but most of them you
wouldn't want to get anywhere near
[Laughter]
stay stay far out as far away as we are
from the Sun yes question what caused
the black hole to be at the center of
the galaxy in the first place what
former no what caused the black hole to
be at the center of the galaxy Oh what
caused the black hole would be at the
center of the galaxy well see the center
of the galaxy tends to pull things in in
fact if you just had stars stars would
tend to pull on each other and pull each
other closer and closer well now when
you get very close to stars maybe would
merge more stars and merge more material
fall maybe the firstly to make a very
big star then enough material falls in
then maybe that would collapse into a
black hole but a small one only a few
masses stellar masses perhaps and then
other material as it falls in towards
the center but accumulate there so the
center is a natural place for everything
to be pulled in and gradually accumulate
and we'll all fall in there eventually
they'll all fall in but you know be some
I don't know hundred billion years maybe
a something like that before we fall in
because we've got to bump into something
to knock us closer towards it lose
eyeing a momentum but it's very natural
that everything gravitates towards the
center mass accumulates there and then
if black holes can exist that milos mass
are going to pull each other together or
more strongly and form a black hole okay
thank you just as you reach the speed of
sound you get a concentration of
particles it produces a sonic boom when
you get to a critical mass for the
formation of a black hole you get a
similar type of concentrated wavefront
is there a critical mass critical mass
concentration of particles is there a
concentration of particles before the
black hole forms
Justin Tom oh yes well sure so far as we
know these are these are normal
particles before before the black hole
is formed and they attracted and they
pull together and on black hole now some
we may even have some stars which in
exploding stars explode they normally
they might form a neutron star for
example but in principle it might form a
black hole
star explodes throwing some material out
and condensing some other material they
may be a moderate number of smallish
black holes around various places and
maybe we'll see be seeing some radiation
from them we have to decide what's a
neutron star and what's a black hole and
so on but the material is ordinary
material before it before it falls in
and then from there on they can't
describe it anymore
as we just have no contact with it now
let me say that Hawking has done some
interesting theory and say well things
can't escape from a black hole and
that's right if it's a very very small
one then you've got a very very small
chance of one part of a particle getting
out in principle something can get out
but in in real practice why nothing gets
away from black hole something it's
certainly nothing this big nothing with
gets away from black hole this big but
there are quantum mechanical ways of
things getting away burrowing out from a
very small black hole just as their
quantum mechanical ways of something
going through a barrier which you can't
get over the particle can go through a
barrier and instead of getting over it
but that has no real effect on the
things we're discussing
please I actually have two questions
first was I was wondering I've read via
vaguely remember reading something that
says it's possible for two black holes
to kind of merge together it is that
true can they just kind of join together
to form a larger black hole sure it
actually doesn't just have a more
massive one and the radius just
increased yeah two black soul two black
holes can come together and form a more
massive one okay my other question was
how what is different between what's the
difference between these mini black
holes that you hear about and these
other were standard black holes that
form from well the many black holes are
black holes we know we've never seen and
we can theorize about them but we've
never seen them we're never made them
and they'd be pretty dangerous if we had
them floating around so one one simply
theorized is about them the theory seems
right but whether they ever get formed
we don't know for sure the big black
holes are ones we can see and we can see
them because they are big and they're
doing very big things out there and
that's why we see them but sadly there's
some smaller ones but I don't know how
small I think we'll take this the last
question is that is a black hole the
antithesis of the Big Bang in other
words the black hole is sucking bad or
in the Big Bang one the antithesis of
the other in a certain way yes in fact
someone asked about our own universe I
own the universe is expanding and from
the original Big Bang so calls expanding
now if there's enough mass in our
universe it'll expand for a while and
then stop and then contract and fall
together and some people will fellow
that's great it'll just you know our
universe is always been here just
contracts and then explodes again and so
on but the theory says if it contracts
and falls together it'll be a black hole
and never come out of it again so yes
the black hole is for the whole universe
contracting if it did that it would be a
black hole and that's the end of it so
far as you know
so in certain sense you can say yes
there they are the Antipodes
[Applause]